ありがとうございますみなさんこんにちは
今日は2030年の世界を考えるということで私は
sdg ずについてお話ししたいと思いますみなさん
sdg ずというのはご存じですよねたぶん最近よくメディアでも取り上げられている
のでここにいらっしゃる皆さんでしたご存知だと思うんですが
国連が2015年に定めた
世界共通の
目標です
17のゴールからなりますけれどもまあこの sdg ずについてお話しする前に少し
mdg ずについてお話したいと思います
mdg ずミレニアム開発目標と言いますけれどもこの
ミレニアム開発目標はメディアぬ year 2000年に出されたミディアム宣言と
いうのがあるんですけれどもそれに沿って作られた目標ですで主に途上国の貧困問題に
ターゲットを上げていますけれどもそのゴール市は
極度の貧困と飢餓の撲滅ということで1日1.25ドル未満に生活する人口の割合を
半減させるあるいは日がに苦しむ人口の割合を半減させるということ
これはまあ一番大きいですけど他にも教育ですとか
保健医療まあ貧困と非常に密接な関係にある
課題が
この mdg ずでは設定されています
達成目標年が2015年だったわけですけれどもじゃあそれがどうだったかというと
実はあああ
ちょっと進んでしまいましたはい
貧困者数については19点2億人から発展3億人と非常に大幅に減っています
また5歳未満の子どもの死亡数も1000270万人から
600万人と半減しています
そして
[音楽]
ください
はい
a チャイブ a ずこれも治療薬が普及したということで非常にあの声で亡くなる方
というのも減ってきています
このように mdg ず非常に良い結果を出したという風に見えますけど実は丁寧に見
ていくと例えば
貧困者数が非常に減ったのはなぜかというと大きく貢献したのは中国やリングです
でそれに対してサブサハラアフリカの国々ではその貧困者の数の縁に津田全然あの
少ないということで地域や国によってその進展には差がある
また1つの国の中で格差の問題が深刻化しています
そしてこの mdc ずに取り組んだ15年間の間にせ管理の環境非常に変化しており
ます
まずは気候変動皆さんも日々感じていると思いますけれども地球温暖化で例えば大型の
台風がいくつも来たり
テリア号があったり数年前には熱帯性の a 病気
デング熱が優美公園で発生
吸うということもありましたこのように気候変動の影響は大きい
そして資源エネルギー食料の問題ですけれども
新興国の経済発展に伴ってエネルギーや食料を非常に需要が増えていて
2020年までに需要が20%増加するとそういう中でおそらくこのままでは私たち
日本もそういった影響を受けることが懸念されます
そして都市化の問題実は現在と指示向こう世界の半分
ブームを占めていますそれが2030年には60%を超えるということも言われてい
ます
都市化が進むと都市のインフラ整備が必要ですそういうには非常にあの
たくさんの資金が必要になりますまた都市化が進むと都市の環境問題ゴミですとか耐久
戦といった問題も深刻化していきます
ん
のように世界でまそもそも mdg ずでもまだ残された課題があるということを
さらに世界の状況変わってはなかなか代も増えてきたということでなんとかしなきゃ
いけないん
ということでこの sdg 頭が定められたわけです
ここでちょっと mdc スト sdg ずを比較してみたいと思いますけれどもまず
mdg
通話先ほどお話したように途上国が中心でしたでも今度の sdg 頭が日本も含む
先進国を含む世界共通の課題として設定されています
そして mdg ずでは貧困健康教育といった社会開発課題がターゲットだったんです
けれども
sdg ではそれに加えて経済面環境面でも重視しています
そしてそれではすべて別々に存在するのではなくて相互に非常に密接に関わり合って
いるということで方
かつ的に対応しようということでそのためにいろいろなアクターのパートナーシップ
これが一つのキーワードになっています
そして mdg 頭が過去のデータや現状をもとにした目標まあいってみれば積み上げ
てこれくらいだったらできるかなといった目標だったのに対して
sdg ずは先に2030年にこういう世界があってほしいとそれを描いてそのために
まあ今何をすべきかという未来志向の非常に野心的な目標になって
います
そしてへ
sg mdc ずではなかなかその各社のところまで目が行き届いていなかった
そういう反省のもと sdg ずでは誰一人取り残さない
特に脆弱な立場に置かれた人々に目を向けて誰一人取り残さない包摂的な社会を築こう
というそういう理念で作られています
今の野心的な目標と言いましたけれどもちょっとターゲットを見るとそれが分かります
例えば
ゴール市の貧困撲滅のターゲット1-1というのがあるんですがそれはあらゆる場所で
極度の貧困を撲滅するすなわち
撲滅ゼロにするということを言っています
そして保健会健康のゴールさんでも
すべての国で新生児死亡5を出生1000件中12件以下にと
例えば来2015年にサブサハラアフリカでは29件なんですねそれを半分以下に12
点にするとさらに5歳未満児死亡率は25件以下という目標ですけれどもこれもさ
ブサ肌アフリカでは83件ですねもう半分よりもっともっと減らさなければいけない
非常にチャレンジングと言えます
そしてあの
次の健康の道路交通事故死傷者を半減というの子でもですね
例えば日本ででもこれやらなきゃいけないそう考えたときに今までと同じようなやり方
ではとても半分になど平瀬ないそういう非常にまああのチャレンジングな目標が中に
入っています
そしてこうしたチャレンジ運輸な目標を達成するためには社会変革が不可欠です
でそれはすなわちあなたな技術などによるイノベーション
そして資金についても今まで以上の資金の動員
さらに私たち一人ひとりがライフスタイルを変革する
そうしたことを守って初めて社会変化
5話遂げられるそしてそうした社会変革にはすべての人々が関わって幅広い
パートナーシップを持って進めていく必要があります
日本もすでに動き出しています安倍首相がヘッドで全閣僚が参加する sdg ず推進
本部というものを設けました
そしてその下にですね円卓会議というのを設置してここには市民社会からあるいは民間
から研究者各省庁
いろいろな方が参加しているそこで
日本政府の指針等は議論されて0最終的に2016年の12月1年前ですね
sdg ず実施指針というものも決定されましたそこでは持続可能で強靭そして誰一人
取り残さない経済社会環境の統合的向上が実現された未来への先駆者を目指すという
非常に高い目標
方針がビジョンが掲げられていますそのうえで日本国内での取り組みと国際協力双方を
推進していこうという形になっています
そして民間セクターでも非常に動きが活発化しています
esg 投資これは社会や環境への配慮あるいうが情報公開だとか
法の順守とかそうしたことに積極的に取り組む t o に投資をするという考え方
ですけれども
今年の7月ニュースになりましたが gpif という私たちの年金を得運用している
機関ですけれども
そこが1兆円規模でこの esg 投資を開始しました
すなわち esg 投資の考え方と sdg ずのかが片方向一にしておりますので
sdg ずへの取り組みが企業価値を高めるということで各企業においては
sdg ずの経営戦略への取り込みあるいは sdg ずを通じたこれまでの授業の再
点検
さらには
持続可能な新しいビジネスモデルの模索というものが非常に活発化してきています
続いて jica が何をしているかも少しご紹介します
まずこれはケニアの事例ですけれどもケニアの保険セクター
ユニバーサルフェスカバレッジこれも最近割合ここあの何年かであの有名になった言葉
なんですがちょっとあのわかりにくいかもしれません
要はすべての人が適切な保険サービスお支払い可能な費用で受けられるようになるそう
いった状態ですけれども
ケニアにおいて jica や世銀郵政 ia id などさまざまな機関が連携して
ケニアで
ユニバーサルフェイスカバレージを実現するために必要な協力技術協力あるいは資金の
援助も行っていますそれにより無償の参加サービスを
受けることができるようになるそうした方が広がるあるいは
貧しい方も健康保険に加入できるようになる
さらにはそういった保健行政を動かす保険部局の能力強化ということも図っています
ですのでこの事業をですねす dg 頭で考えてみるとまずは当然ゴールさんの兄
健康そして合わせて貧困層が保健医療サービスにアクセスできるようになるということ
では貧困の削減ということで撲滅ということでゴール一致
そしてすべての人に公平に保健医療サービスが届くという意味ではゴールド中の不平等
をなくすとそういったところにも同時に
貢献していると言えます
次のでは京都大学との連携です京都大学が
a
マレーシアですねマレーシアの経済特区
経済特区に指定されますと当然経済開発が進むということで
に参加たり炭素の排出が増えるということが懸念されていますのでそこで日本の経験を
基に低炭素社会のしないようの構築手法で協力するということで
2025年の二酸化炭素排出量を40%削減するという計画を作りました
そしてそれに沿って植林活動あるいはコンポストの推進
公共交通機関の利用促進などそういった取り組みを
まあ実施しているところですがこの授業であれば
11の都市問題そして13の着込む変動に貢献しているといいます
そして3つ目は企業との連携事例です
これはガーナなんですけれどもガーナではその離乳期の子どもたちが栄養不足で成長
不良発育不良を起こしているということが課題になっています
ですのでその改善のために味の素がサプリメント
離乳食に加える栄養サプリメントここ+というものを開発しました
jica ばは同協力したかというとそのガーナでの市場調査ですとかビジネスモデル
の開発
あるいは事業計画の策定というところでサポートを致しました
さらにですねあのもっといろいろな方が加わって
usaid wfp といった期間も一緒になって
ここ+を普及させるための持続可能なビジネスモデルの実現
それに取り組んでいます
今のところですね2017年までにすでに2万人の子供にこのここ+が届けられてい
ます
これは当然健康ゴールさんそしてやはり貧困撲滅ゴール市と不平等をなくすゴール集
全てに貢献していると言えます
ここまで2030年にこうあってほしいという目標
3g ずと日本がすでに動き出しているということをお伝えしましたけれども
じゃあ今私たちが何をすべきか何をできるかです
まず一つ目は sdg 頭を自分に当てはめて自分の生活
どう見直すのは自分ごととして捉えるこれが大事だと思います
例えばそのゴール中にの作る責任使う責任このターゲットはステラ l 食料を半分に
する
あるいは3 r reduce reuse recycle でゴミをなくす英語が
ゴミを減らすそういったことがターゲットになっていますけれども
これは私たち一人ひとり身近なところでできることです
一つひとはとても小さなことだけれどもそれが集まれば大きな変化を生みます
そして例えばゴール後ジェンダー平等これは日本がまだ達成できていない目標の一つ
ですけれどもこれも例えば自分が男女の役割分担な
などステレオタイプなモノの見方をしていないかなあと自分に問いかけてみるそういう
ことが大切だと思います他にも電気や水を無駄にしてないかとか
弱い立場に
ある人に配慮しているかそうしたことを sdg ずを物差しに一人一人が考える
そうしたことができると思います
そしてそういう自分の身の回りのことと合わせて世界の問題にも目を見てたい
今やもうグローバル化で世界で起こっていることがそのまま直接的に私たちの日々の
暮らしにも影響してきます
そうした中でやはり皆さんにはぜひ世界にも目を向けて興味を持っていただきたい
できれば海外に行っていただきたい海外に行ってその国の人々にも会い話をし
感じてほしいあの jica 青年海外協力隊を派遣してますけれどもそういった
ところに参加するのもひとつの方法です
ぜひ世界を4 d 多様な価値観に触れて若い学生の今のうちから柔軟性発想力を養っ
ていただきたいと思います
そして3点目が何度が出てきましたパートナーシップキーワードです
今はここにいらっしゃる皆さんもあと何年かすると社会に出ます
おそらく企業で働く方あるいは行政機関にスマイル方研究を続ける方いろいろあの
スイングチュア
まちまちだと思いますでも伊豆での道に進んだとしても今ここにいる皆さんがぜひ領域
を超えてつながりあい連携
して日本や世界の課題に取り組んでいただきたい
小さちょうど昨日の事なんですけれどもここ関西の地で関西 sdg ずつアット
フォームというものが立ち上がりましたこれは関西地域の企業や自治体 ngo npo
字浴衣方が連携して
sdg 角た
生に向けて新たな価値を生み出すような活動あるいは
イノベーションそういったことを取り組んでいこうというそういうプラットフォーム
です
2030年までもう12年しかありません
今ここにいる学生の皆さんそして私たち社会人
みんな一緒になって今から考えて
行動を起こしたいと思います
私からのプレゼンテーションは以上です
[拍手]